Barack Obama gave a number of interviews,
including to CBS's 60 Minutes, which we will
get to, but also to Gayle King.
And it was very interesting to hear Barack
Obama's perspective on the last four years
and on the election that Joe Biden has defeated
Donald Trump and the implications.
And one of the messages that Barack Obama
focused on, not just in this interview, but
in others as well, is that this is not normal
and it's an important message.
We've been talking about hyper normalization
for four years.
Let's take a listen to the former president
here.
I think we were in a circumstance in this
election in which certain norms, certain institutional
values that are so extraordinarily important
had been breached that it was important for
me as somebody who had served in that office
to simply let people know this is not normal.
So I've talked about this and I talked about
this when Donald Trump was elected and we
saw things are going to be insane.
I started saying I am going to try to prevent
the normalization of insanity.
And it's something we've continued talking
about and we've had to fight and it happens
to all of us.
There is no way to see daily scandal and embarrassment
and humiliation day after day after day and
not to some degree become desensitized to
it, to another attack on the media, to another
attack on democracy, to another attack on
the sort of fundamentals that this country
is based on.
And Barack Obama nicely lays out, this is
not normal.
None of this is normal.
And Barack Obama also lays out that he's very
concerned about the 72 million people that
voted for Donald Trump, whose world view is
largely informed by radical right wing media,
exactly as I've been talking about for the
last several months.
Take a listen to this.
Seventy two million people voted for Donald
Trump.
What does that say to you about the state
of this country?
Well, what it says is that we are still deeply
divided.
The power of that alternative worldview that's
presented in the media that those voters consume,
it carries a lot of weight.
Are you worried about that?
Yes.
It's very hard for our democracy to function
if we are operating on just completely different
sets of facts.
But it's clear as we sit here today, we're
not going to have a peaceful transition.
I think about John McCain calling George and
Laura Bush welcoming you and Michelle Obama
to the White House could not have been more
gracious.
I remember you inviting Donald Trump to the
White House.
If you succeed, then the country succeeds.
I wish that you succeed because we want the
country to succeed.
He does not seem to have taken a page out
of any of those playbooks.
No.
So what is at stake here?
Well, look, Joe Biden will be the next president
of United States.
Kamala Harris will be the next vice president.
There is no legal basis.
There's no getting support from members of
the Republican Party who are not challenging
him.
And that has been disappointing.
But it's been sort of par for the course during
these four years.
They obviously didn't think there was any
fraud going on because they didn't say anything
about it for the first two days.
Barack Obama was also asked about his demeanor
on the campaign trail when he was out there
for Joe Biden over the last few weeks.
And Barack Obama pointed out that he was not
so much going in on Trump.
He was stating facts.
He was just repeating things, Trump said verbatim.
It wasn't personal, actually.
What you didn't have I've had it moment.
The truth is everything I said, I was just
stating facts.
You've got a president right now.
He wants full credit for an economy that he
inherited.
He wants zero blame for the pandemic he ignored.
It was out of character for you to speak up,
Mr. President.
That way I was not the person who, at a White
House briefing room said, how is Bletch the
way to solve it?
I wasn't doing a routine.
I was repeating words that I heard.
We talked about how it is really difficult
to massively deprogram millions of.
Lists and case in point, last week I took
a very interesting call from from a fellow
YouTube who has a small channel who said,
David, I was able to do it.
I'd programed a trumpet and I said, great,
well, so how did it happen?
And the guy said, well, I had him on my YouTube
channel for three hours for a one on one conversation.
And that is a very difficult timeline for
the massive deprogramming of 72 million people.
Now, you can say you don't have to deprogram
all 72 million.
If you can deprogram 10, 15 percent of them,
you're already shifting the electoral balance
dramatically.
But the first step to massive deprogramming
has to be massive normalization.
It has to be the masses must re realize they
must again come to realize that this is not
normal, that it's whacked.
I don't really know how to do it.
One thing I thought about over the weekend
was with the realization that Trump doesn't
care about them, play a role in the deprogramming.
And what I mean by that is Donald Trump's
supporters are people that Trump wouldn't
be caught dead with.
Most of Trump supporters are people Trump
has spent his entire life avoiding by flying
private and living where he has lived and
so on and so forth.
And you just have to look at this weekend
for a perfect example.
There was this big protest in favor of Trump
in D.C., people going crazy.
And we'll talk about that a little bit later.
Trump literally drives by the protest, waving
from inside his armored vehicle on his way
to spend the weekend playing golf.
He doesn't care about them.
And I'm just thinking out loud here.
If Trump supporters came to really understand
that Trump doesn't give to, you know, what's
about them, would that help to deprogram them?
And I'm reminded of an LBJ quote, Lyndon B.
Johnson, the former president, who said, if
you can convince the lowest white man that
he's better than the best colored man, this
was the vocabulary of the time.
He won't notice you're picking his pocket.
Hell, give him somebody to look down on and
he'll empty his pockets for you.
That's who Trump has targeted and who primarily
has to be deprogrammed.
So, bottom line, I'm glad Barack Obama is
saying these things.
I'm disgusted and horrified that things like
this have to be said, that it has to be mentioned.
Trump continuing to claim he won is a disaster
for the for the United States.
It's an embarrassment.
Trump attacking the media, Trump attacking
these fundamental institutions.
The fact that we have to mention, hey, guys,
by the way, this is bad.
This isn't normal.
That's the tragedy.
And a peaceful transfer of power, of course,
is important.
Joe Biden, one that's not a controversial
thing to say, or at least it shouldn't be.
But 86 percent of Trump voters don't believe
that Joe Biden legitimately won.
I imagine that as we get closer to inauguration,
that number will decline.